हेलो एवरीवन
गुड इवनिंग
चाट में प्लीज बता दीजिए
ओके ओके थैंक यू तो आज हम टॉपिक स्टार्ट
करने से दो एक मिनट और वेट करते हैं
उसके बाद हम कंटिन्यू टॉपिक स्टार्ट
करेंगे
तबीयत खराब थी मैं अच्छा फूल नहीं कर रहा
था और मैं क्लास लवी नहीं पता क्योंकि गले
से आवाज भी निकाल रही थी दिस इसे डी
प्रॉब्लम
1 मिनट बस 1 मिनट
एक बार मैं क्या करता हूं ना की लास्ट
क्लास में हमने इनपुट आउटपुट रिएक्शन के
बड़े में पढ़ा था तो मुझे लगता है की शायद
थोड़ा सा जो कॉन्सेप्ट था फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन का जब वहां पर डिस्कस हुआ था
ना मुझे लगता है की वहां पर आपको एक थोड़ा
सा पिक भी कैप चाहिए
की मुझे अगर मैं आपको थोड़ा सा क्विक रिकप
कर दूंगा ना तो लगता है की जो आपको थोड़े
से इशू है आबे होंगे समझना में क्योंकि आप
लोगों के लिए नया कॉन्सेप्ट था जो सबने का
काफी अच्छे से आपको पढ़ना पटाया था और
शायद किसी ने रिवाइज किया हुआ है हो सकता
है आपको कुछ की कॉन्सेप्ट छठ रहा होगा तो
मुझे क्विक रीकैप करता हूं चाहे मुझे 10
से 15 मिनट दीजिए क्विक टाइप करने के लिए
आपके इस कॉन्सेप्ट को की उसके बाद इट्स मी
गारंटी 100% सर की आप लोग भी हैं उसे
कॉन्सेप्ट को इतने अच्छे से क्लियर हो
जाएगा और जो उसके बेस पे हमने इनपुट
आउटपुट रीडायरेक्शन का जो प्रैक्टिकल आप
लोगों को करवाया था लास्ट क्लास में वो
बहुत क्लियर हो जाएगा आपको एक बात मेरा 10
तू 15 मिनट का जो क्विक पिकअप कर लीजिए ये
चीज उसके बाद क्या करना है
जितना भी करवाया था सर ने उसको एक कम
कीजिए आप वहां पर जाकर उसको देख लीजिए
दोबारा से उसे इस रीकैप के बाद अगर कोई
डाउट हो तो फिर बताना उसके बाद डाउट नहीं
आने वाला तो मैं वो चीज आपको समझने जा रहा
हूं अभी बोर्ड की हेल्प से की अब कैसे आप
लोगों को चीज समझनी है मैं आपको बताता हूं
ठीक है
थोड़ी सी गले में प्रॉब्लम है तो प्लीज
डोंट मन अगर आवाज में मेरी प्रॉब्लम हो
जाए तो बीच में देखो उससे पहले नहीं आपको
हर चीज एक चीज जानवी बहुत जरूरी है सबसे
पहले आपको एक चीज जानी जरूरी है क्योंकि
जब भी आपके सिस्टम में कोई भी प्रोसेस
स्टार्ट होती है कोई भी प्रोसेस बाय
डिफॉल्टर वो बहुत साड़ी लाइब्रेरीज का उसे
कर दी है कोई भी मैं आपको अगर मैं अभी
दिखाऊं
जब भी कोई प्रोसेस
आपकी सिस्टम में स्टार्ट हुई
ठीक है
वह क्या करती है
बहुत साड़ी प्रोसेस को क्या करती है उसे
करती है
प्रोसेस क्या होती है प्रोग्राम क्या होते
हैं जो बेसिक कॉन्सेप्ट है इतना तो मैं
समझ सकता हूं की आप लोगों को आता होगा
इन क्लास तू जो दे तू क्लास थी उसमें
मैंने जब फाइल सिस्टम हायर के बड़े में
बताया था वहां पर मैंने एक चीज के बड़े
में डिस्कस किया था की स्लैश बिन डायरेक्ट
फिर जो बाइनरी वाले डायरेक्टली थी जब
मैंने वो डिस्कस किया था आप लोगों के साथ
तो वहां पर मैंने एक चीज को उसे किया था
जो कमांड सी उनके बड़े में थोड़ी सी एक
चीज को टच अप किया था उसको मैं फिर से भी
क्या उसको रिकप करते हुए आपके कॉन्सेप्ट
को पकड़ता हूं वहां पर मैंने क्या डिस्कस
किया था की आप चाहे अपनी मशीन में
उसे करो
डब्लू सी कमांड उसे करो बी कमांड उसे करो
सीडी कमांड कोई भी कमांड आप क्या करो उसे
करो
वह सारे के सारे क्या है वह सारे के सारे
आपके हैं प्रोग्राम
एग्जीक्यूट होते हैं जब भी यह प्रोग्राम
क्या होते हैं एग्जीक्यूट होते हैं तो
क्या होता है जब यह प्रोग्राम
एग्जीक्यूटिव
तो वहां से आपका क्या बंता है एक प्रोसेस
क्रिएट होती है
अब यह प्रोसेस क्या करती है इंटरनली
को उसे करती है
चाहे यह लाइब्रेरी आपकी
करना लाइब्रेरी
रे करना
है आपका हर एक चीज नेक्स्ट में फाइल्स
होती है और वह
क्या करता है जो लाइब्रेरीज है
कंसीडर
फाइल
कौन सी फाइल
ओपन फाइल
ओपन फाइल्स
ओपन
जो लाइब्रेरीज फाइल्स है जिनको इसमें उसे
कर दिया वह लिरिक्स क्या करता हूं
और वो क्या कर रही है
क्या कर रहा है फाइल कंसीडर कर रहा है
इसलिए कौन सी कंडीशन मांगी ओपन कंडीशन में
इसलिए इनको ओपन कंडीशन में कंसीडर किया
जाता है अब बात करता हूं इसी के आगे इसमें
पार्ट है की जो लाइनेक्स करना था ना जो
हमारा जो लिरिक्स करनाल है
क्या करता उसको
मॉनिटर करने की जरूर है ठीक है
[संगीत]
ट्रैक
करने की क्यों जरूर है
जो सबसे मतलब सॉरी
चीजों के बड़े में मालूम होना चाहिए की
मेरे बच्चे क्या कर रहे हैं ठीक है उनके
बच्चे क्या कर रहे हैं कौन घर में ए रहा
है कौन जा रहा है कौन क्या कर रहा है इसी
तरह से करनाल जो हमारा है वो इस ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम का सबसे बड़ा सदस्य है और सबसे
ज्यादा पावरफुल भी अब ये बताइए अगर उसके
घर में ही क्या हो रहा है उसके घर में कुछ
भी हो रहा हो और उसको नहीं पता होगा तो
क्या हो सकता है सबसे बेड थिंक है उसके
लिए क्योंकि सब कुछ इस को मैनेज करना है
साड़ी पावर उसके पास है और इस को नहीं पता
उसके घर में क्या हो रहा है इसी रीजन से
जो लिरिक्स करनाल है
उसको क्या करना था इन फाइल्स को ट्रैक
करना था मॉनिटर करना था मॉनिटर करना क्यों
जरूरी है जब तक वह किसी चीज को मॉनिटर
नहीं करेगा तब तक उसे पर कंट्रोल नहीं कर
सकता सिंपल सा मतलब है अब इन ओपन फाइल्स
को मॉनिटर करने के लिए इंडेक्स को क्या
करना पड़ा एक कॉन्सेप्ट उसे करना पड़ा जी
कॉन्सेप्ट का नाम है
फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन ठीक है इन ओपन फाइल्स
को क्या मॉनिटर करने के लिए कॉन्सेप्ट आया
फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
किया था उसको थोड़ा सा और क्लियर कर देता
हूं एक छोटे से रीकैप करो
बेसिकली बोल सकता हूं की जो फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन है आपका
उसको हम उसे कर सकते हैं
[संगीत]
ठीक है आज जो फाइल सिस्टम को हम क्या कर
सकते हैं इस कॉन्सेप्ट को उसे कर सकते हैं
मैनेज करने के लिए ओपन फाइल्स को लेने के
ऊपर अब क्या होता है की लाइनेक्स में या
कोई भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम होता है उसमें
क्या होता है ना की डिफरेंट डिफरेंट
टाइप्स की टेबल का उसे किया जाता है उनमें
से कुछ टेबल्स हैं जो मैं क्या करने वाला
हूं आपको डिस्कस करना है करने वाला हूं
अभी फाइल जो डिस्क्रिप्शन का कॉन्सेप्ट
उसको समझने के लिए क्योंकि उन टेबल्स को
जब तक नहीं समझाऊंगा आप फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
के कॉन्सेप्ट को नहीं समझ पाओगे तो मैं एक
सिनेरियो लेते हुए एक डायग्राम के साथ
आपको समझने की कोशिश करूंगा लेकिन पहले
मैं बता देता हूं की वे कौन-कौन सी टेबल्स
है जिनके बड़े में अभी डिस्कस करने वाला
हूं
सबसे पहले जो बात करते हैं हम जी टेबल्स
की मैं बात करने वाला हूं सबसे पहले मैं
बोल सकता हूं आई नो टेबल
आई नोट टेबल
दूसरी में बात करने वाला हूं ग्लोबल
फाइल टेबल
तीसरी बात करने वाला हूं जो है फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन
टेबल
स्पेशल टाइप ऑफ
टेबल है अब एक और चीज इसके बड़े में
अपडेट कर सकता है
इंपॉर्टेंट बात यह है की जो प्रोसेस चीज
क्रिएट की गई और जो प्रोसेस है उनके अंदर
जो फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन को खुद ही मालूम
नहीं होता क्योंकि यह एक हिडन टेबल होती
है ये एक हिडन टेबल होती है जिसको सिर्फ
करनाल ही अपडेट कर सकता है
जो प्रोसेस है जिसकी फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन
टेबल है वह उसको अपडेट नहीं कर शक्ति
उसमें कोई भी चेंज नहीं कर शक्ति अगर उसको
कोई भी चेंज करवाने होंगे कुछ भी करना
होगा तो वह करनाल के द्वारा ही पॉसिबल है
इसके अंदर क्योंकि चीजों को अपडेट मॉडिफाई
वैल्यू चेंज करना सब कुछ करना नहीं करता
है अब बात आई है यहां पर
इतनी इंपॉर्टेंट कैसे टेबल
चलो आप लोगों के दिमाग में सवाल होगा
इसीलिए एक नया कॉन्सेप्ट निकाल दिया फालतू
में कम बड़ा दिया ऐसा नहीं है देखो यह
अकेला
उसे हनी है उसमें कम सोना ही है तो उसके
लिए क्या है फाइल तो ओपन हनी ही है ठीक है
तो अब
इसके और भी दो एक-दो इंपॉर्टेंट पॉइंट है
जिनके बड़े में आपको अभी बताता हूं
यह क्या करता था जो
प्रोग्राम है जो आपका प्रोग्राम जब
प्रोसेस क्रिएट हुई उसकी हेल्प भी करता है
उसकी हेल्प कैसे करता है मैं बताता हूं
हो हिट हेल्प
तू प्रोग्राम
या हम बोल सकते हैं प्रोसेस
कैसे देखो क्या करता है सबसे पहले कम करता
है
दूसरा क्या करता है
ऑन डी
फाइल सिस्टम
वेयर
इसे
फाइल्स स्टॉक
है एक तो प्रोग्राम्स जो है उनको यह समझना
में हेल्प करता है की जो हमारा फाइल
सिस्टम है उसे पर यह फाइल कहां पर स्टोर
है कहां पर राखी हुई है मुझे कहां से उसको
एक्सेस करना है दूसरा ये वो इनफॉरमेशन
देता है की क्या मैं इस फाइल को एक्सेस कर
सकता हूं यानी कर सकता मतलब क्या है की
स्पेसिफिक परमीशंस के बड़े में बता देता
क्या इसको एक्सेस करने की मेरे पास परमिशन
है या नहीं यह भी चीज इसके थ्रू आपको पता
चल जाति है वह कैसे पता चलती है अब मैं
आपको समझता हूं की वो कैसे पता चलती है
मैंने क्या बताया स्टार्टिंग में आप लोगों
को
अगर किसी को अगर स्क्रीनशॉट लेना है ले
लीजिए लो अगर आपको थोड़ा सा क्या राहत है
की बाद में समझना होता है ना की एक बार आप
इसको अगर स्क्रीनशॉट लेना चाहते हैं तो ले
लीजिए आपकी मशीन में सो डेट की आपको आसानी
से नोट्स बनाने में हेल्प हो जाए
स्क्रीनशॉट ले लिया होगा चलो
एग्जीक्यूट करने पर प्रोसेस
में क्रिएट हो जाता है
और जो यह है ना यह साइड में यह क्या है
यह
फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन नंबर
होता है आपका
पॉजिटिव
इंतजार
होता है यह आप लोग समझ में ए गया होगा
उसका रेफरेंस मिलता है यहां पर यहां पर
क्या हो सकता है कोई भी बाइनरी नंबर
एड्रेस यहां पर हो सकता है इसके इस टेबल
के अंदर अब ये क्या है इसमें रेफर किया
रेफरेंस दे दिया हमें किसका
अंदर अब ये है आपकी ग्लोबल फाइल्स टेबल
देखो ये ये भी इस तरह के जो होती है
ठीक है अब ये देखो ये आपके ग्लोबल फाइल के
ऊपर इसको हम बोल सकते हैं
किया इसमें जो एड्रेस था
आपको एक रेफरेंस प्रोवाइडर
रेफरेंस तू आई नो टेबल
नो टेबल
भारत की इसमें जो एड्रेस दिया
पर्टिकुलर फाइल
होता है वह इनफॉरमेशन ठीक है
उसका साइज हो जाता है उसका टाइम स्टांप हो
जाता है उसकी लोकेशन होती है यह साड़ी चीज
मटर डाटा के अंदर आई है तो किसी भी फाइल
का मटर होता है ये होता है तो वो
इनफॉरमेशन यहां पे मिलेगी साथ के साथ यहां
पर क्या है ये एक रेफरेंस देगा की आपको ये
फाइल फाइल सिस्टम पर कहां पर स्टोर फाइल
सिस्टम का एक एड्रेस रेफर करेगा की आप
वहां जो फाइल सिस्टम के अंदर वहां जाकर आप
क्या करो इस फाइल को सर्च कर लो देख लो
यहां से आपका कम बन जाएगा
बेसिकली यह था आपका फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन का
कॉन्सेप्ट
[संगीत]
बता दीजिए अगर यह रिपीट करना है तो
अरे सबको क्लियर
बता दीजिए चाट में
क्लियर है
देखो क्या ना की मैंने क्या किया आप लोगों
को एक कहना की जब एक प्रोग्राम क्रिएट हुआ
प्रोग्राम से क्या प्रोग्राम ने
एग्जीक्यूट किया प्रोग्राम ने प्रोसेस
क्रिएट भी प्रोसेस को जब एक किसी फाइल को
उसे करना है तो उसके बिहाइंड का एक छोटा
सा कॉन्सेप्ट बताया है अगर आपको बिल्कुल
ही की उसके बड़े में पढ़ना है की ये हर
चीज
बुक कैसे कम कर रही है ये चीज कैसे कम कर
रही है उसके लिए मेरे दोस्तों मेरे भाइयों
आपको नहीं है क्या करना पड़ेगा आपको
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की आर्किटेक्चर को पढ़ना
पड़ेगा यह तो बिल्कुल एक बिल्कुल ऊपर ऊपर
से मैंने क्या किया मैंने भाषा में समझने
की कोशिश किया है
क्योंकि यह कॉन्सेप्ट बहुत बड़ा है अगर आप
फाइल टेबल के बड़े में जान कुछ करोगे आई
ऍनोड टेबल के बड़े में जन का आई नोट नंबर
क्या होता है की यूनिक नंबर
जितनी भी फाइल्स क्रिएट होती है चाहे वो
बाय डिफॉल्टर हो या आप क्रिएट करो एम्टी
हो कैसी भी हो हर एक गे यूनिक नंबर डिसाइड
किया जाता है इस की हेल्प से ही तो पहचाना
जाता है ये है वो कॉन्सेप्ट क्योंकि किसी
भी फाइल को ओपन करोगे हर एक प्रोसेस को
क्या करना है एक फाइल को ओपन करना ही
पड़ता है ओके तो अगर आपको ज्यादा दीप में
पढ़ना तो आप पढ़ सकते हो जाइए बुक रेफर
कीजिए ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम और आर्किटेक्चर
पड़ी है उसके बड़े में
कैसे एक प्रोसेस कम होती है कम करती है
कैसे प्रोसेस क्रिएट होती है कैसे ऊपर से
शेड्यूल होती है कैसे वो राम में अपलोड
होती है
कैसे वह कैसे मजा आई है कैसे क उसको
शेड्यूल करता है यह साड़ी चीज आपको पहले
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के बेसिक नॉलेज में मिले
उसके बाद आपको क्या है जब उसकी
आर्किटेक्चर पढ़ोगे तो हार्डवेयर पार्ट्स
से रिलेटेड इनफॉरमेशन मिलेगी बाकी समझना
के लिए आपके लिए फाइल्स डिस्क्रिप्शन
में किया नहीं होगा अगर किया हो की मेरी
तो नजर में नहीं आया अभी देखें कॉन्सेप्ट
अब इसी में थोड़ा सा आगे बढ़ते हैं की में
टॉपिक क्या था की ठीक है अब मैंने क्या
किया की जो फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन के बड़े में
बताएं डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन टेबल ऐसे कम करती है
अब जो हमें सीखना था ना जो अब हमने सीखना
था
वो ये पार्ट है वो पार्ट है यह
फाइल डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर बोले
की जो फर्स्ट थ्री एंट्री है ना हमें इस
से मतलब है
आपको देखने को मिलेगी
प्रोसेस में देखने को मिलेगी यह वह कौन सी
एंट्री में बताता हूं आपको यह वह एंट्री
है जो लास्ट क्लास में आपको बताया गया था
यह
एसटीडी इन जीरो
एसटीडी आउट वन
एसटीडी
लास्ट
में थी उसमें आपको बताने की कोशिश की गई
थी जो मुझे लगा की आपको थोड़ा सा और
ज्यादा बताना था एक चीज बताओ
इनपुट डिवाइस
कौन सा है हमारा
कीबोर्ड
हरे प्रोग्राम के लिए स्टैंडर्ड इनपुट
डिवाइस कीबोर्ड है और बाय डिफॉल्टर ही
हमारा
स्टैंडर्ड
आउटपुट और
डिवाइस
वह क्या
है
ब्यूटीफुल कैमरा
टेबल में देखने को मिलता है
[संगीत]
अब यहां पर क्या होता है
कंडीशन आई है की मुझे क्या करना है की
किसी भी प्रोसेस के लिए प्रोग्राम के लिए
इस बाय डिफॉल्ट कीबोर्ड को उसे नहीं करना
मुझे बाय डिफॉल्ट वाले कीबोर्ड को उसे
नहीं कर रहा था ना चाहता हूं की इसकी मैं
किसी फाइल को फाइल को उसे करूं इनपुट की
जगह
किया उसे प्रोसेस में प्रोसेसिंग की उसका
जो आउटपुट आया उसको मैं क्या करना चाहता
हूं किसी के इनपुट देना चाहता हूं
की मैं क्या चाहता हूं की जो भी मेरा
आउटपुट आता है एसटीडी आउट का या एसटीडी
एरर का
[संगीत]
मैं चाहता हूं मैं किसी फाइल में शेर करूं
मैं नहीं दिखाना चाहता की मेरा क्या
आउटपुट आता है
जो हम लास्ट क्लास में पढ़ा था
इनपुट
और आउटपुट रीडर
इनपुट आउटपुट
डायरेक्शन यही वह कॉन्सेप्ट है जो लास्ट
क्लास में आपने पढ़ा था क्योंकि हम जितना
पढ़ा
वह क्या है जो प्रैक्टिकल करके दिखाए
करते हो यह
आपका कॉन्सेप्ट
की यह कॉन्सेप्ट
बोरिंग है या यह कॉन्सेप्ट हमें समझ में
नहीं आया या यह हमें ऊपर से ऊपर ऊपर से
गया है तो इससे लेमन भाषा में ये
कॉन्सेप्ट आपको मैं बता रहा हूं हिंदी में
तो युटुब पे नहीं मिलने वाला फाइल
डिस्क्रिप्शन के बड़े में बिल्कुल ही इजी
भाषा में मैंने ये करवाया है
अगर किसी को लगता की है तो बताना मेरे को
बाय डी वे ये आपको नहीं देखने को मिला है
कंचन क्योंकि ये ऐसा कॉन्सेप्ट है अगर आज
आपको ये क्लियर हो गया एटलिस्ट अगर जिसका
क्लियर होगा अच्छी बात है जो अभी क्लियर
करना चाहता होगा अपनी क्लास के बाद अगर
जैसे ही वीडियो अपलोड हो जाति है 2 मिनट
के बाद एक मिनट के बाद ही तो आप इसको
दोबारा से एक बार वीक कर लीजिए इस
225 मिनट के उसको तो आपको मैं बता रहा हूं
एवं कोई भी कमांड आप उसे करना जो भी कल
जितनी भी एग्जांपल्स आपको क्लास में बनाए
गए थे अब इस कॉन्सेप्ट को एक बार समझना के
बाद एक बार वीडियो देखने के बाद क्या करना
है
ये कॉन्सेप्ट था
ओके तो यह है कॉन्सेप्ट
बात करने की जरूर नहीं है क्योंकि बेसिक
जब आपका मैंने कॉन्सेप्ट यहां पर क्लियर
करवा दिया तो अब प्रैक्टिकल को खुद से
करना चाहिए की जो लास्ट क्लास में हुआ था
प्लीज को थ्रू आईटी
1 मिनट का समय दीजिए मुझे स्क्रीन स्विच
करने दीजिए उसके बाद फिर कंटिन्यू करते
हैं हमारे कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट और टॉपिक भी हैं
जो अभी स्टार्ट होने वाले हैं और स्टार्ट
हो रहे हैं धीरे-धीरे
मुझे आपके थोड़ा चाट भी नजर रखना पड़ेगा
तो मुझे एक बार थोड़ा सा मुझे भी देखने
दीजिए
ओके वर्मा जूम कर देता हूं थोड़ा सा
टर्मिनल अपना
बता दीजिए लाइव
ब्लैक स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है
चलो देखो लास्ट क्लास में क्या किया था
मैंने कैट कमांड के बड़े में बताया था
बहुत साड़ी कमेंट्स के बड़े में बताया था
फिर से हम कमांड का सिलसिला शुरू से
स्टार्ट करते हैं देखो क्या है की जब
मैंने कैट कमांड के बड़े में आपको बताया
था तो कैच कमेंट आउटपुट कैसा आता है वो
पूरा का पूरा डिस्प्ले कर देता है क्या हम
कुछ ऐसा कर सकते हैं की जो जो हमारा
आउटपुट हो वो ऐसे दिखाई दे की मुझे टॉप से
इतना देखना है बॉटम से इतना देखना है या
मुझे मिडिल से इतना देखना है तो ऐसा कुछ
करने के लिए मुझे आउटपुट अगर मुझे ऐसा कुछ
आउटपुट देखना है तो उसके लिए मुझे क्या
करना पड़ेगा उसके लिए मुझे दूसरी और कमांड
का उसे करना क्योंकि जो कैट कमांड है
उसमें ऐसा कोई ऑप्शन नहीं है उसमें ऐसा
कोई ऑप्शन नहीं है
रिफ्रेश
इट्स वर्किंग फाइन ओके
बॉटम आपके आउटपुट को शो करती है हा ए ए डी
जो एक हेड कमांड होती है
और जैसे मुझे एक फाइल होती है ईटीसी के
अंदर एक पास डी फाइल होती है अब मैंने
किया तो ये क्या कर दी है
एक बार मैं स्विच कर लेट हूं अपनी मशीन को
मेरी फाइल है
ओके अल्लाह
अगर मुझे क्या करना है
जो आपकी जो एड कमांड होती है
लेकिन बाय डिफॉल्ट नंबर ऑफ 10 को शो कर
दिया अगर आप चाहते हो 10 से ज्यादा लाइनें
को आप देखना चाहते हो वो कैसे देख सकते हो
वो भी मैं आपको बताता हूं
मैं देखना चाहता हूं
तो 15 उसके बाद क्या करना है आपको लिख
देना उसे फाइल का नाम या उसे अगर आप किसी
प्रोग्राम्स के आउटपुट को देखना चाहते हैं
तो क्या करना पड़ेगा पहले आपको उसका
प्रोग्राम उसका नाम लिखना होगा उसके बाद 5
सिंबल का उसे करते हुए आपको क्या करना
होगा उसका आउटपुट को उसके इनपुट को इसके
हेड कमांड के इनपुट में देना होगा
इसमें क्या है टॉप 15 लाइन को यहां पर शो
किया है यहां पर
123456789 अगर आपको अगर मैं दिखाऊं कैटमैन
से तो क्या करना था ये तो स्लैश ईटीसी
स्लैश फास्ट डी अब ये क्या है बहुत सर
आउटपुट है वैसे वो स्क्रीन को क्या फाइल
कर देता था लेकिन आपको क्या करना है ओनली
10 लाइन का चाहिए 10 लाइन का देख सकते हो
अगर आपको क्या करना ओनली तो टॉप फाइव लाइन
का देखना था उसके लिए आप उसे कर सकते हैं
हेड आईफोन 5 उसके बाद उसे फाइल का नाम
ईटीसी
फाइव लाइंस का ये आउटपुट शो करेगा आप मुझे
क्या करना है की मुझे करना है की मुझे
मोटर से
बॉटम से आउटपुट देखना है लेकिन लास्ट की
लाइन से देखना है तो उसके लिए कमांड होती
है तेल तेल उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
स्लैश ईटीसी स्लैश फास्ट डाउनलोडिंग
कमांड होती है वह
नीचे से
10 नंबर ऑफ 10 लाइंस है उनको क्या करता है
उनकी आउटपुट को स्क्रीन पे शो करते हैं
इसमें भी ऐसे ही ऑप्शंस हैं अगर आपको क्या
करना है की बाय डिफॉल्टर से ज्यादा अनसुल
आउटपुट कुछ शो करना है वो भी कर सकते हो
कम करना वो भी कर सकते हो तेल उसके लिए
उनका तेल उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है
सिंपली आप उसे करोगे जी नंबर ऑफ लाइंस
कितनी देखनी है आपको अगर फाइव देखनी है
बॉटम से तो वो भी आप देख सकते हो सो लेट
सी बी टी सी पास डाउनलोडिंग
शो कर देगा तो ये थी हेड और तेल के बड़े
में इनफॉरमेशन जो आपको पता होना चाहिए था
अगर
उसके बाद मैं कंटिन्यू करता हूं की एक और
कमांड होती है जो जिससे आप अपने फाइल से
कंटेंट को लिस्ट आउट कर सकते हो वो कौन सी
कमांड होती है
[संगीत]
यह क्या चीज है थोड़ी सी इसके बड़े में
इन्फो देता हूं
जिसका उसे टेक्स्ट फाइल के कंटेंट को रीड
करने के लिए किया जाता है ना ये आपका जो
आउटपुट है ना उसको पेज बाय पेज बाय शो
करता है ऐसा नहीं है की कैट ने जैसे क्या
किया की आपकी पुरी स्क्रीन पे पूरे आउटपुट
को दिखा दिया और आपको क्या करना स्टोर्ड
डॉ करना पड़ता है अब ये बहुत ही छोटी सी
फाइल है इसका आउटपुट बहुत ही छोटा सा है
अगर थाउजेंड्स लाइन है तो आप करते-करते
आपके आ बहुत टाइम वेस्ट हो जाएगा तो इसके
लिए क्या है की तेल कमांड उसे कर सकते हो
हेड कमांड उसे कर सकते हो अब ली कमांड भी
है तो इसको कैसे उसे कर सकते हैं हम आपको
दिखता हूं मैंने क्या किया मेरी एक डेमो
फाइल थी तो मैं क्या कर रहा हूं ली एक
डेमो नोट
टी एक्स टी ए वाली फाइल है आप मुझे क्या
करना है अब इसमें स्क्रीन पे पेज पे पेज
भाई ये लोड करेगा अब मुझे एक चीज बताइए की
जब भी आप किसी भी फाइल्स के कंटेंट को रीड
करते हैं तो उसके लिए क्या करते हो आप
लाइन बाय लाइन आउट आउट नहीं पूरा पेज पढ़
लेते हो और इंपॉर्टेंट भी आपको तभी दिखेगा
तो आप क्या करोगे की आप लाइन बाय लाइन
पढ़ोगे तो अब आपको क्या करना है की इसको
रीड आउट करना है मुझे टॉप तू डॉ जाना है
उसके लिए मैं क्या करूंगा सिंपली प्रेस डॉ
अरा डॉ अरा को पता कीबोर्ड में है जो अरा
राहत है डॉ वाला ठीक है तो सिंपली क्या
करो जैसे मैं डॉ अरा प्रेस करते रहो देखो
ये लाइन बाय लाइन में चला रहेगा कंटिन्यू
प्रेस करोगे तो पास-पास जाएगा अगर आपको
बॉटम को टॉप जाना है मतलब आपको ऊपर जाना
है उसके लिए आपको उसे करना है आपको क्या
उसे करना है आप अरा अब ये क्या लाइन बाय
लाइन बाय अब क्या आउटपुट कुछ शो कर रहा है
अगर आपको क्या करना है पेज बाय पेज क्या
करना है आपको स्टेप आउट करना है आपको क्या
करना है एक पेज से दूसरे पेज पे दूसरे पेज
से तीसरी पेज पे तो उसके लिए आपको कीबोर्ड
में प्रेस करना है पेज अप पेज अप जो की
शब्द होता है उसको प्रेस करना है आपको
कीबोर्ड में पेज आप देखो ये अभी पूरा पेज
बाय पेज बाय शिफ्ट करेगा अब देखो अगर आपको
क्या करना है
पेज अब सॉरी
टॉप जाएगा अगर आपको क्या करना है की टॉप
तू बॉटम जाना है तो नीचे जाना है पेज बाय
पेज तो आपको क्या करना है पेज डॉ देखो ये
पेज डॉ आपको पेज बाय पेज नीचे लेकर जाएगा
अगर आपको क्या करना है ऊपर जाना है पेज
बाय पेज उसके लिए पेज अप आपको ये शब्द का
उसे करना है अगर डॉ करना है तो पेज डॉ ये
क्या करें आपको पेज भाई पेज आपको क्या
करेगा मूव करवाइए अगर लाइन बाय लाइन आपको
मूव करना है उसके लिए आपको डॉ अरा और आप
पैरों का उसे करना है अगर आपको क्या करना
है इस फाइल के अंदर आपको क्या करना है कुछ
सर्च करना है इस फाइल के अंदर अगर सर्च
करना है वो भी कैसे टॉप को बॉटम आपको पता
है टॉप तू बॉटम कैसे होता है ये रहा ऐसे
अगर ऐसे आपको इस फाइल में सर्च करना है
टॉप तू बॉटम तो उसके लिए सिंपली आपको
प्रेस करना है पहले फॉरवर्ड इसमें यहां पर
ध्यान दीजिए अभी देखो मैं जो हाईलाइट कर
रहा हूं इधर ये था इधर ध्यान देना अभी
जहां पर मेरा ये अभी मैं उससे आपको दिखा
रहा हूं हाईलाइट करके तो यहां पर क्या
करूं जैसे ही आप क्या करोगे
एक्सप्रेस करोगे
उसके बाद आपको क्या करना है उसे पैटर्न का
नाम देना है या उसकी शब्द का नाम देना जो
इसके अंदर सर्च करना था तो सो डेट की आपको
कम आसन हो जाए मैं क्या सर्च करना चाहता
हूं एचडी ये मैंने सिंपली क्या कर दिया अब
इसे क्या कर दिया उसे पैटर्न को जहां-जहां
मैच किया उसको हाईलाइट कर दिया अब मुझे
क्या करना है की टॉप तू बॉटम जाना है तो
मुझे क्या करना है अब ये क्या टॉप तू बॉटम
आपको शो कर रहा है तब मुझे डॉ जाना है
मुझे अब नेक्स्ट हाइलाइटेड की शब्द पे जा
रहा है क्योंकि स्पेस में तो इतना ही
दिखाई दे रहा है उसके लिए आपको क्या करना
सिंपली प्रेस और होता है नवंबर वाला एन
उसको प्रेस करना कैपिटल
पर यह रहा ऐसे सर्च करना है तो आपको
सिंपली क्या करना है उसके लिए आपको उसे
करना है क्वेश्चन मार्क देखो अब जो मैंने
क्वेश्चन मार्क प्रेस किया शिफ्ट के साथ
क्योंकि फॉरवार्डशिप के साथ उसे करोगे तो
उसके ऊपर होता है क्वेश्चन मार्क तो
क्वेश्चन मार्क उसके बाद उसे पैटर्न का
नाम लिखिए तब मैंने क्या कहा था इसमें
पैटर्न ढूंढ रहा हूं सिस्टम एस ए एस टी ए
एम सिस्टम और हिट इंटर कर दिया अब देखो
सिस्टम आपको हाईलाइट हो गया ऊपर क्योंकि
अभी ये क्या है इसमें जो सर्च किया है
इसने ऐसे सर्च किया अभी अब मुझे क्या करना
है नेक्स्ट में जाना है तो सिंपली प्रेस
और फेयर प्रेस और के देखो ये पैटर्न भाई
पैटर्न जाएगा अभी देखो फिर से मैंने
नेक्स्ट प्रश्न
ऐसे ये क्या कर रहा है
अब क्या करना है आपको ये आपको अगर आपको
क्या करना है की
आपका कर्सर कहानी पर अगर आपको इस फाइल के
और में जाना है सिंपली इस फाइल
आपको प्रेस करना है आपकी कीबोर्ड में और
जो एक और कीवर्ड होता है आई एन दी उसको
प्रेस करो अब देखो आप इसके और में अगर
आपको ये स्क्रीन पे शो भी कर रहा है की
बॉटम में की हां आप और में हो अब आपको अगर
यहां से क्या करना सीधा या तो आप क्या
करोगे पेज भाई पेज भाई जाओगे लाइन बाय
लाइन सॉल्व करोगे एडरवाइज अगर आप
डायरेक्टली क्या करना चाहते हो की आपको
फ्रंट लाइन पे जाना चाहते हैं पहले वाली
लाइन पे स्टार्टिंग
प्रेस करना पड़ेगा
अब मैंने जैसे ही होम प्रेस किया अब मैं
कहां पर हूं मैं सबसे टॉप पेज को सबसे
पहले वाले पेज पे अपलोड तो ये था कुछ इसके
बड़े में ली कमांड के बड़े में उसे करने
के बड़े में सो डेट की आप इसको फैमिली और
हो जो अगर देखो जो भी साथ में नोट्स बना
रहे हो तो जो जो मैंने बोला की मैंने कहा
उसे किया इसका क्या प्रपोज सब अपना एक
नोट्स में बना लीजिए
और अगर मुझे इससे बाहर जाना है मुझे इसको
क्या करना है आउट होना है क्यूट करना है
तो सिंपली क्या होगा टर्मिनल को कट नहीं
करना है की भैया मुझे शाउटेड सीधा अरा
दिखाई दे रहा इसको कट कर डन नो आपको
सिंपली प्रेस कब स्मॉल क्यों होता है
विदाउट शिव के साथ और विदाउट कैप्स लॉक ऑन
ठीक है तो आपको क्या करना है प्रेस के ऊपर
प्रेस क्यों करते हैं आप क्या करोगे इसका
मां से बाहर ए जाओगे क्यूट कर दिया है ऐसे
एक मोर कमांड होती है मोर कमांड भी ऐसे ही
कुछ कम करती है तो वो आप खुद से प्रैक्टिस
कर लीजिए अब मैं आपको कुछ और बताना चाहता
हूं कुछ और कमेंट्स के बड़े में अब जैसे
की आपको अभी तक आउटपुट क्या टॉप तू बॉटम
देख लेते हैं कैट का आउटपुट एक और कमांड
होती है
कमांड क्या करती है जो आपका आउटपुट होता
है उसको बॉटम तू टॉप दिखाई है मतलब ऊपर से
नीचे उल्टा दिखाई है अगर आपको क्या करना
चाहते हो आप उल्टा देखना चाहते हो रिवर्स
करना चाहते
हैं साथ में फाइल का नाम ईटीसी का नाम फिर
पांच डी फिर ये है आपका हिट इंटर कर दीजिए
अब ये क्या कर रहा है
अगर आपको इसका मैं अगर आपको आउटपुट दिखाऊ
तो ये देखिए अब ये है अगर मैं दिखाऊं तो
ये है
देखो अब इसमें क्या है
आपको और उसमें बॉटम में क्या था रूट था
मतलब ये फाइल क्या है
तो इसमें
[संगीत]
ऐसे ही है मतलब आपको बेसिक के लिए क्या
करना है की आपको कंटेंट को कैसे रीड करना
फाइल के ये आपको पता चल गया होगा अब देखो
आपको क्या करना है नेक्स्ट जो टॉपिक है वो
पढ़ने वाले हैं की अगर फाइल को फाइल में
आपको क्या करना है की काउंट करना चाहते हो
की कितने नंबर ऑफ लाइंस हैं कितने नंबर ऑफ
शब्द हैं कितने नंबर ऑफ फैक्टर्स हैं
पर्टिकुलर किसी फाइल कंटेंट के अंदर ये
कोई भी फाइल जैसे ईटीसी की फाइल है इसके
अंदर कितने नंबर हो शब्द है कितने नंबर
कितने नंबर ऑफ लाइंस है अगर आपको उनकी
काउंटिंग रखना चाहते हो उसको काउंट करना
चाहते हो तो क्या करोगे ऐसे तो ना बैठे
उसके लिए कमांड होती है
वर्क और इसका सिंटेक्स कैसा होता है ब्लू
सी उसे करोगे
वर्ल्ड काउंट बोलते हैं इसको उसके बाद आप
उसे करोगे
ऑप्ट ऑप्शन ठीक है उसके बाद आप उसे करोगे
ऑप्शंस के बाद आप उसे करोगे फाइल नाम फाइल
नाम
अब इसको मैं कैसे उसे करके दिखता हूं देखो
मैंने क्या किया डबल्यू शब्द काउंट अब
स्लैश सीटीसी प्लस पास डी हिट इंटर किया
अब इसमें क्या कर दिया जो ये फाइल थी
स्लाइस सीटीसी फाइल थी इसके अंदर
599 है मतलब जो क्या है की जो फर्स्ट जो
आपको ये दिखाई दे रहा है ये शो करता है
आपका
नंबर ऑफ लाइंस ये नंबर ऑफ शब्द
हैं 97 शब्द है और 59 क्या है ये आपको शो
कर रहा है
लाइंस लाइंस अगर आप क्या करना चाहते
हो
ओन्ली
599 है इसके अंदर आपको ओनली आप क्या करना
देखा शब्द को देखना चाहते हैं तो उसके लिए
एक फ्लैग होता है वर्क हिफिन ब्लू ये नंबर
ऑफ शब्द को शो करेगा अगर आप ओनली करैक्टर
को देखना चाहते हो तो वर्क हिफिन
शो करेगा लेकिन एक चीज ध्यान में रखना की
जो डब्लू सी कमांड होती है वो कभी भी आपकी
कमांड के ऊपर नहीं चलती जब एक एलएस सीपीयू
कमांड होती है अलग सीपीयू एरिया ये कुछ
इनफॉरमेशन प्रोवाइड कर दिया
आर्किटेक्चर के बड़े में
अभी अलग सीपीयू ऐसा नहीं है की मैंने इसके
अंदर के नंबर व्हाट्सएप
करोगे
अब मैंने फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन का और
कॉन्सेप्ट आपको समझा दिया है इनपुट आउटपुट
रीडायरेक्शन तक की जन का अब उसको कैसे
पकड़ना है ये आप लोग को अच्छे से आना
चाहिए अब ये क्या है इसने क्या कर दिया है
को आउटपुट था किसका इनपुट बनाऊंगा मैं
वर्क कमांड का उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं
इसके अंदर 38 लाइन है
286004 इसके अंदर कैरक्टर्स हैं तो यह कुछ
था आपका कौन सी कमांड के बड़े में शब्द
काउंट कमांड के बड़े में वर्क कमांड के
बड़े में
अब एक चीज मैं आपको
कम कर रहे होते तो एक चीज होती है की जो
हर कोई लाइनेक्स एडमिन फॉलो कर लेना यूजर
फॉलो करता है वो क्या चीज होती है की सबसे
पहले हम क्या करते हैं ना हम ट्राई करते
हैं की जो भी हमें कम करना है जो भी
आउटपुट चाहिए या जो भी कम ट्राई करते हैं
वो कमांड से हो जाए फर्स्ट हमारा यही राहत
है सेकंड अटेंड क्या करते हैं की हम यह
कोशिश करते हैं की उसे कमांड्स के ऊपर
जितने भी फ्लैग हैं उनका उसे करके अगर
हमारा कम हो जा रहा है तो उसको हम ट्राई
कर देंगे
आप कमांड उसे करके भी वो कम नहीं कर का
रहे और ना ही आप जो ऑप्शंस है उनको उसे
करके वह कम कर का रहे तो फिर आप क्या करते
हो कमांड को जोड़ना शुरू करते हो जोड़ने
के लिए आप उसे करते हो पाइप चेंबर का जैसे
की मैंने अब क्या किया इन दो कमांड को
जोड़ा इन दो कमांड को मैंने क्या किया
जोड़ा तो इस तरीके से उसके बाद क्या करते
हो अब जब आपने फर्स्ट स्टेप फॉलो कर लिया
सेकंड स्टेप फॉलो कर लिया फर्स्ट स्टेप पे
आता है की आप कमांड को जोड़ना शुरू करते
हो जोड़ के आप कैसे अपना आउटपुट निकाल दे
की कोशिश करते हो
तो अब
तो अब बात करते हैं हम एक ऐसा टॉपिक
जिसकी मैंने आप क्लास में बता रहा था की
अनाउंसमेंट में भी हमें बात की थी
सबसे इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक तो मेरा वही था की
आपको फाइल डिस्क्रिप्शन समझना
डिस्क्रिप्शन जाना दूसरा देखो क्या है ना
की
अब जो मैं कमांड उसे करने वाला हूं की जी
कमांड की मैं सीरीज स्टार्ट करने वाला हूं
ना आपको समझने के लिए
चाहे वो कोई भी लाइनेक्स एडमिन हो या आपकी
लाइनेक्स की स्पीड को मतलब एक आपको
स्क्रिप्ट लखनी है कुछ भी करना चलेगी
बताया जाएगा
वह सीरीज बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग सीरीज
मैं बोल रहा हूं की आपने अभी तक चलो ठीक
है जिन लोगों ने मिस किया है कर दिया
करो पुरी क्लासेस अटेंड करने
जा रहा क्योंकि नेक्स्ट टाइम जब आप
रिवीजन करते हो दोबारा क्लास को देखते तो
सोच लो इसका मतलब आप वो चीज आपको याद हो
रही है आपको सुनकर बैठोगे तो भी प्रॉब्लम
है एडरवाइज आप बिल्कुल रिकॉर्ड सेशन देख
रहे हो तो बस आपकी और ओन्ली
मत करो तो अब जो सीरीज की बात करने वाला
हूं तो यह काफी इंटरेस्टिंग सीरीज है
जिसमें हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं उसकी पहले
लिस्ट आउट करके आपको एक लिस्ट दिखा देता
हूं की हम कैसे डिस्कस करने वाले हैं इस
सीरीज के अंदर आने वाली मुझे काफी अच्छी
सी चीज है कमांड्स की
एक बार मैं आपको जूम करके दिखा देता हूं
डिलीट कर देते हैं
सबसे पहले हम पढ़ेंगे
सेंड कमांड के बड़े में
तीसरा पढ़ने वाले हैं
कट कमांड के बड़े में
डिटेल कट कमांड के बड़े में
लॉकेट
कमेंट
के बड़े में
यह सीरीज है
क्योंकि मोदी इंपॉर्टेंट सीरीज है मतलब यह
साड़ी की साड़ी क्या ना इतनी इंपॉर्टेंट
कम ऑन इतनी इंपॉर्टेंट कमांड अगर आपने
इनको उसे करना सिख गया ना तो आप नहीं किसी
भी आउटपुट के साथ
बहुत ही आसानी से क्या कर सकते खेल सकते
हो खेलने मतलब की कैसे आपको इतना जल्दी शो
करना है की अगर आपको बोला की मुझे ये
फाइल्स फाइल में से मुझे ये आउटपुट कैप्चर
करना है मुझे पकड़ना है मुझे क्या करना है
फाइंड आउट करना है
बहुत ही ज्यादा इजी क्योंकि यह
सबसे बेस्ट
पढ़ने का भी कोई फायदा नहीं है
आप कुछ भी कम करो
सबसे पहले हम डिस्कस करने वाले हैं
स्टार्ट करते हैं एसिडिटी क्या होती है
उसको हम बोलते हैं
सरिता एडिटर
उसके बाद हम उसे करते हैं
सिंगल को सिंगल को के अंदर एक्शन हमें
क्या करना है उसके बाद फाइल नाम
उसके बाद क्या करोगे
प्रिंटिंग मतलब आप क्या आउटपुट को
प्रिंटिंग का कम करती है प्रिंटिंग ऑफ
इन मेट्रो मैनर
ओके
तीसरा
डिलीट करने का कम करती है
आफ्टर डी लाइन
नंबर
प्रिंट कर सकते हैं इस कमांड की हेल्प
करते थे और डेमो
ये है फाइल देखो इसके अंदर बहुत ज्यादा
आउटपुट मैंने आप लोगों के लिए निकाल गई है
इसके अंदर लोग फाइल जाएंगे तो अब मैं इसको
सेट कर को कैसे उसे करूंगा तो इसके लिए
सबसे पहले सेट उसके बाद सिंगल को सिंगल को
के अंदर मुझे क्या करना है मुझे पहले क्या
करना है
क्या करना है की मुझे इसकी फर्स्ट वाली
लाइन को प्रिंट करना है प्रिंट करना है
उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं
ना इसके साथ आपको फ्लैग उसे करना होता है
अगर वो फ्लैग उसे नहीं करोगे ठीक है ये
अपना पुरी की पुरी फाइल को क्या कर दिया
प्रिंट करके दिखा दिया
तो आपको अगर इसके साथ सही से कम करना है
प्रिंटिंग कॉरपोरेशन
के अंदर वन पी मतलब फर्स्ट लाइन उसके बाद
में क्या करना है उसे फाइल का नाम स्लाइस
सीटीसी
पास डी हिट इंटर अब इसने क्या किया है ना
आपकी ओनली पहले लाइन को प्रिंट कर दिया
ओनली पहले लाइन को प्रिंट कर दिया अब मैं
एक चीज क्या है अब मुझे क्या करना है की
इसका मां के बड़े में एक चीज बतानी भूल गए
हम आपको
पेपर बता देता हूं की देखो अभी तक मैंने
जितनी कमर पढ़ाई हेयर तेल
नहीं पड़ता मैं ऐसे कम मुझे करना आता नहीं
टॉप कर दें यह जो कमांड कम करती है ये कम
करती है लाइन नंबर पर हमेशा लाइन नंबर पर
कम करती है
अब सबको पता है की जो लाइन नंबर कैसे कम
करते हैं टॉप तू बॉटम लेकिन सेट कमान क्या
करती है उसे टॉप तू बॉटम बॉटम टॉप समझ में
नहीं आता ओनली जो लाइन नंबर पर कम करती है
कम करती रही है ठीक है अब मैं क्या नंबर
लाइन नहीं दे रहा मैं देखो अब मैंने क्या
का रहा है आउटपुट शो कर रहा हूं तो शायद
हिफिन एन मुझे प्रिंट करना है फर्स्ट वाली
लाइन को अब मैं कहता हूं की मुझे इसमें एक
बार मैं एक आउटपुट अगर आपको शो करके
दिखाऊंगा कैट करके दिखता हूं आईफोन एन के
साथ देखा हूं तो नंबरिंग के साथ आपकी फाइल
का पुश होगा ईटीसी और फास्ट डाउनलोडिंग
करना बहुत आसन हो जाए एक बार मैं इसको
स्प्लिट कर देता हूं एक्शन
ओके
अब मैं क्या करूं मेरे अगर आप की
राइट साइड में देखोगे मैंने क्या किया
इंटर कर दिया अब ये क्या कर रहा है की
थोड़ा सा आउट कर देता हूं तो आपका आंसर
दिखाई दे नहीं थोड़ा सा नोट करना पड़ेगा
लाइन नंबर के साथ इसमें प्रिंट कर दिया अब
मुझे क्या करना है की मुझे फर्स्ट वाली
लाइन है ये वाली ये वाली फर्स्ट वाली लाइन
है और ये फिफ्थ वाली लाइन है मुझे इसका
आउटपुट देख रहा है मतलब मुझे अपने प्रिंट
करना इसी को ही प्रिंट करना है मुझे तो
मैं कैसे करूंगा चाट आईफोन और उसके लिए
सिंगल कोड मैं करूंगा वन उसके बाद वन पीस
वाली लाइन को प्रिंट करना है उसके बाद से
यही कॉलर सेमी कोलोन का मतलब सेपरेटर है
एक प्रकार से उसके बाद फाइव लाइन का उसके
बाद मैं क्या कर रहा हूं उसे फाइल का नाम
दे दो ईटीसी पास डाउनलोडिंग कर दिया अब
इसने क्या कर दिया आपका ओनली ये खुद ही
देखो देखो रूट वाली फाइल इसी को ये क्या
कर दिया इसने प्रिंट कर दिया अब मुझे क्या
करना है नहीं मुझे
327 तक क्या चाहिए
37 अगर कोमा उसे किया है तो उसके बाद 7
उसके बाद क्या करना है पी करना है उसके
बाद आपको क्या करना है छिपकली फाइल का नाम
दे देना स्लाइस ईटीसी और
डबल्यू
बिन गेम
को सीधा डायरेक्ट
आपको लास्ट वाली लाइन कुछ नहीं क्या कर
दिया प्रिंट कर दिया अब ओके लास्ट वाली
लाइन को प्रिंट कर लिया अगर मुझे क्या
करना है फर्स्ट और लास्ट लाइन को प्रिंट
करना वो भी कर देंगे कैसे सेट उसके बाद है
अपन एन उसके बाद सिंगल पोर्ट उसके बाद ये
क्या है ओके वन पीस उसके बाद सेमी कोलोन
उसके बाद $20 भी
उसके बाद ओके ये भी कर देंगे स्लैश ईटीसी
प्लस
लाइन को उसने क्या कर दिया प्रिंट कर दिया
अब मुझे क्या करना है
तो वो भी मैं कर दूंगा तो यहां पर
क्वेश्चन देता हूं जितने भी लाइव आते हो
या इसके बाद जो भी अगर कोई बाद में हमारी
वीडियो को देखेगा तो सबके लिए क्वेश्चंस
है और उसका आंसर आप यहां की कमेंट क्षेत्र
में दे सकते हो
मुझे क्या करना है यही फाइल है आप लोग
सामने जो लेफ्ट में है मुझे इसका एक
आउटपुट चाहिए मुझे क्या करना है मैं इसको
कमेंट आउट करके देखा हूं
नीड
डी
लाइन नंबर
फ्रॉम
वन तू फाइव और
इलेवन तू
15 और
125 और मुझे चाहिए
अगर 50 हो गया उसके बाद
तो मुझे क्या करना है आपको
आउटपुट में चाहिए
खत्म होने के बाद मतलब कैसे
इसको कर देता हूं अब इसकी मुझे एक्चुअल
में वैसे जुड़ तो नहीं पढ़ने वाले बट इट्स
ओके मुझे मैं बैक तू
ओके नो इशू
[संगीत]
क्लियर करने के लिए
ओके
मतलब
दूसरा ऑप्शन हमारे पास
में फाइल मतलब अब मुझे क्या करना स्क्रीन
पर चेंज नहीं करना मैं चाहता हूं
इसका मतलब में फाइल के साथ चेंज चेंज वाले
ऑपरेशन परफॉर्म करना चाहता हूं तो ये दो
ऑप्शंस होते हैं फाइनल रिप्लेस में इस
कमांड के साथ ठीक है
हम कैसे अब मैं सीडी पेपर में क्या करता
हूं आपको कैट करके दिखता हूं कैट / सीटीसी
सब्सीट्यूट मतलब ये क्या करेगा पहले उसको
सर्च करेगा उसके बाद क्या करेगा उसको
रिप्लेस करेगा एस और शब्द ली उसके बाद
यहां पर उसकी शब्द का नाम देना है जिसको
हमें सर्च करना है मुझे सर्च करना रूट ओके
रूट उसके बाद रिप्लेस किसके साथ करना है
मतलब इस रूट शब्द को किसके साथ रिप्लेस
करना है सचिन ओके
लेकिन आपको फाइल नाम फाइल नाम
यहां पर
फर्स्ट लाइन में ओनली जो पहले रूट केवल इस
को सचिन नाम से रिप्लेस कर दिया
ऐसा क्यों
क्योंकि अगर आपको अपनी फाइल में सारे
झूठ की शब्द को चेंज करना है तो आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा उसके लिए आपको एक ऑप्शन इसी
के साथ क्या है एक चीज उसे करने जाते हैं
मैं बताऊंगा एडरवाइज आपको ओन्ली पहले वाले
जो फर्स्ट ऑक्युरेंस होगा सचिन की ओर्गा
जहां को सबसे पहले होगा रूट को अगर इस को
आपको क्या करना है इस नाम से रिप्लेस करना
बेस्ट वे एडरवाइज आपको पुरी फाइल में झाझा
रूट है उसको अगर आपको चेंज करना है उसके
लिए आपको क्या करना है सब इसके साथ आपको
लास्ट में क्या लगा देना है सिंपली जी
मतलब ग्लोबल
फाइल में झाझा रूट हमारे सचिन करना चाहता
हूं बट ये क्या है ऑन स्क्रीन कम हो रहा
है में फाइल में कुछ कम नहीं हो रहा है
देखो
आपको पता चल गया अब
यह तो पता चल गया
अब मुझे क्या करना है
इसके साथ में क्या उसे करूंगा वन|
ओनली इस लाइन में जो रूट था इस को इसने
सचिन से रिप्लेस किया है इसके अलावा किसी
को भी यदि प्लेस नहीं करेगा अब बात करते
हैं अब मैं दिखता हूं आपको अब मुझे क्या
करना है की नहीं मुझे अभी मुझे ऐसा कोई
शब्द ढूंढना पड़ेगा
नो लॉगिन
इनको सचिन के साथ रिप्लेस करने
चाहता हूं फर्स्ट वन तू सेवन लाइन नंबर
1279 नंबर उसके बाद मैं क्या करना
सब्सीट्यूट कौन सा कीबोर्ड 9 लॉगिन
उसके बाद मुझे किसके साथ रिप्लेस करना है
रिप्लेस करना है उसके बाद
देना पड़ेगा
जो पहले सेवन होगी
1234567
है उसके बाद क्या है 9 लोग इन को इसने
रिप्लेस नहीं किया
मैं ऐसा कर देता हूं तो सेट कमांड
के साथ और मैंने क्या कर दिया नो लोग इनका
मैंने क्या कर दिया मैंने कैपिटल कर दिया
अब सबको पता है की लाइनेक्स कैसे सेंसेटिव
है तो मैंने हिट इंटर कर दिया अब ये क्या
करेगा इसको रिप्लेस नहीं करेगा क्यों नहीं
किया रिप्लेस क्योंकि लाइनेक्स के
सेंसेटिव ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है तो यहां पर
क्या है की स्मॉल और कैपिटल और अलग-अलग
मैन जाते हैं अगर अलग-अलग मां जाते हुए तो
अब ये क्या करेगा जहां पर कैपिटल एन वाला
मिलेगा इस को ही दीपेश करेगा अदर वाइस ये
रिप्लेस नहीं करेगा ठीक है अब मैं इसको
क्या कर सकता हूं बाईपास कर सकते हैं मतलब
क्या है की हम कैसे कर सकते हैं बाईपास का
मतलब क्या है की कैसे इन सेंसेटिव बना
सकते हैं उसके लिए फ्लैग उसे है की मैं
चाहता हूं की मेरा जो सेट कमांड है वह
क्या करें कैसे इन सेंसिटिविटी कम करें
मतलब की इसको
ओवरऑल इसको ओवर एड करके रखिएगा सेंसेटिव
कम करता है तो ये उसकी तरफ ना करें इसको
सिंपली जी के साथ आप आई उसे कर लीजिए उसके
बाद हिट और इंटर करोगे तो अब आपको चेंज
देखने को मिलेगा डेफिनेटली दिखे रहा ये
रहा सचिन सचिन आपको देखने का मिलेगा तो
कैसे सेंसेटिव को आपने क्या कर दिया कैसे
इन सेंसेटिव बना दिया इग्नोर करेगा कैसे
सेंसेटिव को
इंस्ट्रूमेंट इंडस्ट्री
[संगीत]
का उसके बाद हम क्या इसको फिनिश करने वाले
हैं 10:30 तक आपको कॉन्सेप्ट खत्म हो
जाएगा
मुझे क्या करना है की अगर मुझे ओनली
क्या करना है की जो मेरा सेकंड ऑक्युरेंस
जो सेकंड ऑक्युरेंस होगा मेरा इसका
पर्टिकुलर अगर मुझे इस को चेंज करना है तो
वो मैं कैसे करूंगा उसको चेंज करने के लिए
सिंपली मैं उसे करूंगा सेट उसके बाद सिंगल
को उसके अंदर मुझे क्या करना है एस उसके
बाद मेरा क्या है रूट था रूट उसके बाद रूट
को मैं किसी चेंज करना चाहता था आपके बड़े
में नाम चेंज करना चाहता हूं ठीक है मेरा
नाम सही करना चाहता हूं ऐसे सी हा आई सचिन
उसके बाद मैं कहना चाहता हूं उसके बाद है
तू सिंपली सेकंड ओनली सेकंड प्रोग्रेस को
ही क्या करेगा ये रिप्लेस करेगा और उसका
नाम फाइल का नाम स्लैश ईटीसी फ्लैश फास्ट
कीजिए अब अगर आप चेक करोगे अपने आउटपुट
में तो क्या होगा ओन्ली जो सेकंड
का तो इस को भी चेंज करेगा बस देखो उसके
अलावा जितने भी रूट है वो आगे आईटी इस
आपको देखने को मिलेंगे अगर मैं चाहता हूं
की
उसके बाद के सभी को क्या कर दे
उसके लिए आपको क्या उसे करना पड़ेगा उसके
लिए आप उसे कर सकते हो इसके साथ लास्ट में
के साथ जी उसे कर लो
तो ये क्या करेगा तू की जगह मैं क्या करता
हूं
और मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं रूट की जगह
1 मिनट इसको
[संगीत]
देखने को मिलेगा
रूट के साथ करते हैं
मैंने उसके बाद मैंने क्या
सचिन
के बाद अब मैं क्या करता हूं
तू के बाद जी करता हूं अगर मैं सबको देखने
को मिलेगा अभी ओके बस इतना भी रूट होगा सब
में सचिन आपको देखने को मिलेगा पता नहीं
भाई इस नोट वर्किंग देवर आप लोग हो सकता
है
अब इसके बाद क्या करता है की अगर आपको
क्या करना है मल्टीपल पैटर्न को एक साथ
सर्च करना है अगर आपको मल्टीपल पैटर्न को
एक साथ सर्च करना तो कैसे कर सकते हैं तो
उसका भी ऑप्शंस है कैसे जैसे की मैं
मल्टीपल पैटर्न को सर्च करने के लिए
9 लॉगिन उसके बाद 9 लॉगिन किसके साथ करना
चाहता हूं नेटवर्क के साथ
नेटवर्क के साथ उसके बाद उसको ग्लोबल
उसे करना है सेपरेट करके उसके बाद क्या
करना है एक और सब्सीट्यूट उसके बाद रूट
रूट को मैं कैसे करना चाहता हूं सच्ची
उसके बाद ग्लोबल जी दें
उसको रिप्लेस कर दिया और जहां पर रूट था
उसको क्या कर दिया इसने सचिन बना दिया एक
तो यह तरीका था अगर आपको क्या करना है
मल्टीपल पैटर्न
आईफोन उसे करोगे सिंपली इसके बाद एक बार
और
रिप्लेस कर सकते हो लेकिन आपको अगर क्या
करना है
मैं चेंज करके नहीं दिखा रहा क्योंकि ये
मेरी ओरिजिनल फाइल है वो कैमरा दिखा देता
हूं एक मिनट
सी उसके बाद में इसका
से कर देता हूं एक फाइल के अंदर
ए गई
मैंने क्या कर दिया से मल्टीपल कमांड्स
वाला है अगर मैं मल्टीपल कमेंट
भी उसे करने वाला हूं
है और यह मेरे फाइल है ओके
फाइल कौन सी रहेगी
व्हाट्सएप
कैट
सैंपल रोटी और अगर मैं क्या करता हूं सेट
सेट आईफोन
के पैसे में कम नहीं
करेगा सैंपल
रोटी एक्सी तो आपको क्या करना होगा देखो
जितने भी नो लोग इन वाली फाइल थी आप नो
लॉगिन वाले कीवर्ड थे आपको देखने को
मिलेगा पेट्रोल के साथ रिप्लेस हो गया
परमानेंटली
सो एक चीज बता देता हूं इसके बड़े में अगर
आपको इसको उसे करना नहीं आता की कैसे उसे
करना है की ऑन स्क्रीन ऑन में स्क्रीन तो
एडरवाइज आपको क्या करना है सबसे पहले
हमेशा कोई भी चाहे आप किसी
अपनी मशीन के साथ करो
तो सबसे पहले क्या की अपने टास्क ऑन
स्प्रिंग परफॉर्म करके देखो डायरेक्ट मैं
स्क्रीन पर में फाइल के अंदर मत करो अदर
वाइस आप करना कुछ ए रहे होंगे तो हो कुछ
जाएगा जिसकी वजह से आपको इन फ्यूचर
प्रॉब्लम फेस ना करनी पड़े
तो आई होप की काफी टाइम हो गया होगा
तो अभी हम सेशन और करते हैं साइड में कुछ
दो-तीन चीज
होना चाहिए आपके लिए भी हमारे लिए भी
तो आयोग
बता दीजिए चाट में
ठीक है